things are changing very quickly right
now
what has changed with russia and ukraine
that you are i'm sure you're following
the story very closely what's changed in
the last three weeks
well the uh
as the situation gets worse
uh for for the russians uh
you know i'm afraid it may move us
closer and closer to the edge you know
of that nuclear precipice
uh
putin has getting
even though uh russia's an authoritarian
state
you know he has
lots of different advisors from the
military from the intelligence services
uh the services the military services
compete with each other
and uh
and and they're probably making
recommendations for all
a wide variety of options nuclear and
non-nuclear options
uh for putin to execute
and uh uh
the longer the conventional war appears
to go against russia
uh the more likely it becomes that one
of these options will be executed
and
uh there's a broad and deep consensus
among the american strategic community
even among people who have been very
anti-nuclear for example anti-nuclear
activists who work for the middlebury
institute of international relations in
monterey who are you know have been
pretty notorious for their anti-nuclear
views are saying that while you know the
russians may well
execute uh some kind of a limited
nuclear attack in ukraine and they
published an article
within the past couple of weeks talking
about what those nuclear options are
you know one of them is an an atomic
demonstration a nuclear demonstration
overnovia's assembly of the russian test
site up in the arctic ocean where they
would
light a nuclear weapon off in the
atmosphere which hasn't been done since
the early 1960s as a demonstration that
russia is serious about going nuclear
another option and i was very pleased to
see that they they mentioned this was an
emp attack on ukraine even the monterey
institute anti-nuclear left is taking
the emp threat
seriously that they would do an emp
attack on ukraine which would fry the
electronics across ukraine
you know disable the ukrainian army and
that would create conditions where the
russian army could now win
you know because the ukrainian army
armed forces would be disabled ed would
as would the whole country of ukraine
because their electric grid would be
down
all the electronics all the
communications would be down and the
third option
that they described
was a actual
limited use of one or a few tactical
nuclear weapons and the ukrainian army
to use blast or thermal effects you know
to blow holes in the army so their guys
could pour through
and uh and uh destroy basically the
ukrainian forces on the ground by means
of of tactical
limited tactical nuclear strikes and i
agree that those are options that are no
doubt being proposed to putin but i
think there are other options that are
are
even more serious that are being
proposed to him
uh you know i think the
one of the options was one of the
scenarios the emp commission had
proposed before there was ukraine war
and that is to do an emp attack detonate
a super emp weapon
70 kilometers high over nato
headquarters in brussels
and this would have the effect of
blacking out
european nato
from ireland all the way to ukraine
and uh that would immediately stop
any uh any arms you know going into
ukraine from from the nato member
countries would paralyze nato so that we
would not be able to intervene in the
nato in the uh in the ukrainian war and
it would send these signals to the
united states that we had better stay
out of it or would be next
and there are there's a faction you know
i think a very influential and powerful
faction within russia that would
advocate that because there are
new thinkers uh who believe
and and they have codified this in their
military doctrine uh that this kind of
an attack an emp combined with cyber
warfare
is the most revolutionary form of
warfare that has ever existed in history
yeah you know because you can at the
speed of light basically take down your
adversary paralyze him and win a war
almost literally at the speed of light
and it would and the initial attack
would kill very few people you know so
it's a clean surgical way of paralyzing
your enemy enemies and winning
uh and uh they have the capability uh to
do that so why not do it and uh they
have been writing in military doctrinal
uh
assessments you know for uh uh almost
two decades about about doing that so
that's a faction that would be saying
you know let uh listen to us vladimir
you know let's do an emp attack that's
not just on ukraine but on nato europe
because it's going to accomplish who's
saying this this is coming from uh this
would be coming from the russian general
staff and those people who who
specialize in in electric electronic and
uh the cyber warriors so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]